price welcome to the show man
congratulations on
on the the new project appreciate you um
colored is the name of the project this
is like kicking off the whole new wave
the whole new like
you know branch of your career thanks
um explain to me the
thought process of i mean audio push is
always going to be audio pushed but in
fact
but having to do like like what what
inspired you to go solo for a project or
is there i mean are you and are you in
octane i know you guys are still cool
but like are you guys still
technically audio push right yeah most
definitely like we
we'll always be audio push you know what
i mean um
that's my brother's [ __ ] his [ __ ] was
12. right right
but um we've also been audio pushed
non-stop for 10 plus years
since i was 17. you know yeah
or something around there like actually
longer than that to be real [ __ ] before
we got popping we got signed at that
time
but i'm just saying that to say it's
been a long time coming since we've like
told our own story
you know we've been advent since we
first were walking up on you in arizona
vegas is when i first met you it was
right oh lord
vegas dog since [ __ ] was popping in
2010 oh yeah
in the back you feel me but um even
since then
you know uh we've always had to just
like fuse our
story in a sense and i should just you
know it's only so much you can do with
that like we order
i got two sons you want to do you want
to tell your story
i got unfiltered un you know raw
yeah what i'm saying we got as much as
me and my brother just alike in so many
ways we also aren't
liking fully different views and a lot
of different things you know and i feel
like in the music and just
this is the chance for me to like fully
express it yeah for sure
so um like you said you have
uh i feel like you always have kind of
been like the more outspoken
like out of you and your uh are you an
octane like i feel like you're
i know where you stand on a lot of
things
you're very opinionated yeah so when i
saw you announce this i was like oh
that's dope like
i really want to hear what this [ __ ]
sounds like and it came out really i hit
you like the album the
dope body of work it's i know it's very
tough like
to deliver like that when there's like
people
people might be like ah you know like
exactly it's very tough to
to deliver and over exceed the
expectations because i was like yeah i'm
gonna check it out but i listened to it
i was like oh this [ __ ] is nice
most definitely especially with all the
like
this out right now like with all the you
know all the music like that you found
yeah
it was like it was a conscious um
intentional
decision that i made like you know one
just
making this my direction my sound
you know what i mean um and my message
but um and then even with just this
being the first project like because
i gotta i got another album drop in
in january you're staying independent
right for sure completely
um most definitely that's a part of
everything we're doing that's a part of
color that's part of the message
um but yeah like
to put colored out knowing that this was
just like i'm gonna just jab y'all
like let me just you know not get up you
feel me like
now i'ma put you down like that's the
that was the intentional thing you know
i knew color like sounds like mufasa and
things like
you know they weren't going to be easy
to digest but the people that were able
to
digest it were going to be fed yeah i
was going to ask you like um
give me the breakdown on the name
colored and
um you know obviously we know that as
an old way that old people would refer
to black people
you know what i'm saying it's almost
like calling asian people oriental it's
like a very dated like
borderline racist thing to say you know
what i'm saying but but what what what
is
the you know the way it's spelled kind
of break down the meaning of that
yeah so um it was just
you know when before quarantine even
happened like actually at like the
beginning of this year
um i just knew like
going into this year octane was actually
making solo music
he was the first one to start making
solo music i remember octane was doing
all kinds of [ __ ] he was like a
photographer
she was dropping videos before she so
yeah i didn't even know that
yeah back in the g he was like dropping
you know he drops a couple
uh solo videos and stuff but um saying
that to say like coming into the year i
knew that i was like going to
take these steps and um i knew
that everything i was going to stand for
the brand i was going to build was just
had to be black as [ __ ] right you know
what i mean
without it being black as [ __ ] you know
or just being all like
just extra ink2 in your face
um i feel like the same way not the same
way but how like [ __ ]
you know that's just a part of like the
average you know
color melanoids vernacular that lives in
the united states
like to me i wanted to make the word
color
be used in a better light like not that
nigga's used in a better light but it's
just used more freely
freely than what it was like the way it
was created
you know and so i feel like colored of
all things because it's a actual beauty
in being colored like that's not a bad
like [ __ ] is some
[ __ ] you like created or
like a word you just you know whatever
but being colored i
actually get charged from the sun this
is actually a
super power i have it's not a bad thing
right yeah no melanin is yours
i win being colored you know i mean it's
not even like that's
just not a science we're not even
talking like opinion
so that was something that just like
i was like you know what i'm about to
i'm gonna finish that
and um just the clrd was just you know
it was like it was god man
the branding like all that [ __ ] was just
like coming to me i wasn't even
asking for it once i just got in harmony
and like
got on the path it literally just
started falling i just wasn't
i was just trusting my god feeling you
know no gut feelings god feeling